如果把一只麦克风放到人类几乎到不了的地方，会听见什么？
世界镜头是地球上最遥远，也最少被打扰的地方。
那里人烟稀少，没有公路，没有信号。
但这并不意味着他们是安静的。
这期节目我想带你去五个真实的世界镜头。
他们是深海、雪山、冰川、火山还有沙漠。
那和村上村树那本小说的名字有点像。
这些遥远的地方本身就带着两种状态。
一种是真正的世界镜头，安静、缓慢、几乎停滞。
另一种是冷酷仙境，他们危险坚硬，随时可能会伤到人。
而我想，此次推荐的五张声景专辑，
就是把这两种状态原来的样子录下的一种创作方式。
那我们之所以能听到这些作品，要感谢一群艺术家和录音师。
他们往往要花几周，甚至几年的时间，等待、跟随、还有记录。
我会先介绍他们的故事，然后每张专辑留出大概五分钟的时间。
和你一起完整的听一段其中的公开视频单击。
接着再继续讲下一个专辑。
那如果你想支持或者收听这些完整版的专辑，
你可以在我的公众号笔卡不利心中找到收听入口。
第一张，深海。
世界镜头的第一个地点是大西洋深处。
这张作品叫做The Wanderer，它可以翻译成漂流者，
那作者是挪威的声音艺术家雅安温德伦。
那雅安温德伦本科学的是海洋生物学，
后来他又读了纯艺术，他常年在科考船上工作，
跟着科研团队记录春季浮游生物爆发的过程，
那全球一半的氧气都是由这些浮游生物光合作用产生的。
那他所创作的The Wanderer这盘专辑，
是他多年里从北极附近一直到赤道，
用水下麦克风，也就是水听器，
沿着大西洋记录不同纬度，不同深度的海水音。
那你在里面能听到非常多的声音来源，
比如虾类靠快速的河笼发出那种喀喀喀的声音，
而螃蟹用复制敲击出那种类似主板的声音。
还有海胆进食时用牙齿刮蹭胶时发出的声音。
那海洋约占地球表面的71%，
而其中九成都是200米以下的深海。
那我们人类观测过的深海海底，
海不到全球深海海底面积的0.001%，
甚至我们对地球表面的了解都比海底多。
那我想这也是这盘能在科研中记录下来的声音专辑大动人的地方吧。
那接下来让我们一起试听一下5分钟的专辑片段。
火山，世界镜头的第二个地点，
是冰岛雷克雅内斯半岛的法格拉达二火山。
那这张叫做Varknik，瓦克宁克的专辑，
在冰岛语中有苏醒的意思。
作者是弗朗切斯科·法布利斯和本弗罗斯特。
那这座冰岛的火山在沉寂了将近800年之后，
在2021年突然喷发。
住在他旁边的两位音乐人在几小时之内就赶到了现场。
他们把录音设备加在离容颜非常近的地方进行录音。
那你现在听到的这首曲子叫做Harmony Terror，也就是斜波颤动。
这个词语是火山学的专有名词，
它专指沿江在地下裂缝里移动产生的那种持续振动信号。
那这张专辑你能听到的大多声音都来自。
沿江冷却时的那种收缩和开裂的声音，
以及气体从容颜里争托出来的那种爆破声。
那其中我最喜欢的一段声音，
它的名字叫做像一条黄家蛇一样下山走向大海。
那这个听着非常金属，非常干脆玻璃的声音。
我虽然无法理解他们具体来自什么样的地方，
但它真的非常迷人、质朴，且充满魔力。
那冰岛的整个国家都坐落在大西洋的终极上，
那两块地窍板块正是在这里一每年几厘米的速度裂开，
沿江从裂缝里涌出来变成新的陆地，
那冰岛这个国家也是这样一点一点的诞生的。
那所以无论我们多么倾向于认为地球是稳定的状态，
它都远非如此。
那接下来我们就来试听一下这张专辑的五分钟片段，
第三张，
高山,
世界镜头的第三个地点，
是瑞士的阿尔卑斯山，少女峰。
这张叫做Esmosphere and Disturbance的专辑,。
可以翻译成大气和扰动。
它的作者是澳大利亚的声音艺术家，叫菲利普·萨马奇斯。
那少女峰是阿尔卑斯山最大的冰川，
阿莱奇冰川的源头，
这里有一座3454米的高海拔研究所，
那作者菲利普·萨马奇斯就是在这里住了四周，
他用全指向的麦克风收录了风雪冰的声音，
还用加速计贴在建筑和机组设施上收入那些振动产生的声音。
那这个研究站在1930年有多国联合基金会创立，
它最早做的是天文和辐射研究，
后来才转向环境和气候研究，
它会持续的记录大气里的温室气体浓度，
而萨马奇斯做这盘专辑就是想用声音记录一件事情，
那就是当一座山经历了气候变化，最先改变的声音会是什么。
那研究站之所以能伤到这么高的地方，
靠的是欧洲海拔的一个最高的铁路，
它叫少女峰铁路，
那这个铁路轨道的大部分都通过早穿山体的内部才可以修通，
所以无论是铁路还是高山轨道的声音，
都成了这里声景的一部分，
你会在同一张专辑里既听到风声，
并穿融水声，
也能听到火车终点站，
观景台，还有设备运转的声音。
那接下来让我们试听一下这张专辑的五分钟声音片段，
第四张，世界镜头的第四个地点，
是日本北海道支床半岛附近的刘滨海域，
那这张专辑叫做留一休，
日语中就是留兵的意思，
作者是日本的生意艺术家上村阳一。
在2019年到2023年期间，
上村阳一连续五个冬天，
回到北海道的支床半岛西侧的玉灯绿。
它把摄位架在这片海滨的上方进行录音，
那专辑在2025年发行，
一共十手三十七分钟。
那我觉得这片支床半岛的浮兵非常有意思，
因为他们能追寻到中国的黑龙江。
当黑龙江的淡水大量流进海洋之后，
它把海洋的沿渡冲淡了，
那这些更容易解冰的海水，
顺着洋流一路向南飘，
于是就最远飘到了日本的支床半岛。
那支床这个名字也很有意思，
它来自爱因奴狱，
本意是陆地的南端，
民间也经常翻译成世界的镜头。
专辑中你能听到冰块互相挤压，
摩擦还有翻滚的声音。
他们有些像木船，有些像金属门，
还有一些像远处声音的动物声。
而其中那种挤压发出接近哨音的声像，
当地人称它为流冰冥，
冥是冥教的冥。
但由于全球气候变暖，
这些冰的厚度越来越薄，
所以哨音已经越来越难被听到，
取而代之的是一种更沉闷的新的声音。
那也正因为记录到了这种正在消失的声音，
这盘专辑获得了Sound of the Year Awards。
正在消失的声音类特别奖。
那接下来我们来试听一下。
这张专辑的五分钟声音片段。
世界镜头的第五个地点，
是南非卡拉哈里沙漠的夜晚。
那这张叫做Midnight at Oasis的专辑，
可以翻译成绿洲午夜。
这张专辑时长28分钟，
在2011年正式发行，
作者是英国的田野录音师克里斯沃森。
那卡拉哈里沙漠横跨波子瓦那，
纳米比亚和南非三个国家，
它的总面积大约90万平方公里，
而它的名字在当地的意思是极度干旱。
但事实上卡拉哈里其实不算一个真正的沙漠，
因为它每年还有一点降水，
所以打不到那种全年无语的沙漠标准。
更准确的说法，它是半干旱生态区，
地表能长出稀酥的草和经济。
那卡拉哈里的咒业温差极大，
很多昆虫和爬行动物都是变温动物，
自己调节不了体温，白天出来就会被晒死，
所以他们只能等到天黑后才敢活动。
这也是为什么这张专辑是克里斯沃森，
录制的是从日落到日出一整夜的声音。
那接下来我们来试听一下这张专辑的5分钟声音片段。
这个星球上大部分的声音从来不是为被谁听见才存在的，
所以我们也再次感谢前面提到的这几位录音师和艺术家。
那希望你们听到的除了这些遥远陌生的时间尽头，
还有这些地方内部细小缓慢，
甚至有些温柔的秩序声音。
那这次推荐也是我本人的第一次尝试，
不知道大家的感受如何，
那有任何反馈你都可以在留言区告诉我，
如果你喜欢本期节目也可以推荐给身边的朋友，
或者在肖宇宙以及苹果波克给我一个五星好评，
非常感谢你的帮助。
那这期节目中提到的专辑，
会把相关信息整理好，
放在我的公众号D卡不利心，
那想支持或者收听完整版的朋友，
可以在公众号D卡不利心中找到入口。
那本期听起来不错，差不多就结束了，
我是D卡不利心，我们下期再见。